[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen nachgemacht original
trifft zelle und zwar werden wir
apfeltaschen machen von mcdonald's ja
ich bin nicht stolz drauf muss ich dazu
sagen aber ich kenne ich noch von früher
und ihr habt das wahrscheinlich auch
schon erlebt apfeltaschen reingebissen
zunge verbrannt und ich finde die
variante aus der fritteuse echt sogar
ziemlich lecker und jetzt wollen wir die
man selber machen
die summe etwas anderes aber es ist ein
gesunder schaue ich glaube kein
nachgemacht rezept von uns ist und weil
wir immer süßwaren nachmachen ja
definitiv eine saison so muss nochmal
wir bauen zb ersten mal zu sehen wie
apfeltaschen aus die gibt es auch alles
kirsch version und schlechten handliches
format und bevor wir jetzt selber machen
das was er natürlich erstmal testen ja
ich habe ein bisschen abkühlen lassen
ich habe mir den marius geschickt
verkleidet in mcdonalds die handtasche
zu kaufen ja ja ich fahre da nicht hin
ja ich habe schon einmal die version
murat wollt unbedingt den kindern ein
eis kaufen also erst dass amira
versprochen und dann war aber irgendwann
schon acht uhr abends und die eisdiele
hat dazu und wo geht es natürlich dann
noch eis weil mancher unserer burger
king und ich habe mit unserem sally bis
dahin gefahren und ich sag noch morath
bitte park beim globus und lauf einfach
rüber und es hat nie sally wer will sich
schon kennen das kennt noch gar niemand
so dann stehen wir bei dem mc drive ich
natürlich beifahrer erfahre
und da hat er bestellt zwei mir ein eis
da man muss es halt was mich ja weil man
muss ihr versprechen einhalten und dann
sagt er ein eis für samira und zwei
cheeseburger und ich da wirklich düster
bestellt hat ja dann immer nach vorne da
wo man eben bezahlt und die ware bekommt
und dann guckt die das war so lustig
nach ob die verkäuferin raus und sagt ja
wenn er denn da werden
sie sind alle kommt dann gucken das
fünfte haus von berger kirche und dann
habe ich ein
und dann hat er hausarrest gekriegt zwei
monate nicht heraus ja das war unsere
geschichte so ja ich probiere ein
kleines stück ach was andererseits aber
ich finde auf jeden fall die füllung
ziemlich schön die ich sehr saftig da
ist mit dabei und die äpfel sind in
würfel geschnitten
also muss ehrlich sagen kann sagen was
will ich bin gut schmecken richtig gut
ja schön groß gar mit mehreinnahmen bei
uns erleben sollte sich jetzt lauwarm
und schmeckt immer noch hervorragend und
jetzt zeigen wir euch noch kurz die
kirche schoko version war das showcar
stoff storkow und mache ich nicht und
die gab es auch in heller version oh
mein gott
wir probieren ganz einfach machen was
gut schmeckt muss gesund sein
auch sei es nachzubauen mit schwere ich
ja ich werde es schaffen und ich
versuche es bei euch nicht zu
kompliziert zu machen
ich mache jetzt erst einmal die
abfüllung und die kirsch füllung und
zeigt euch hier vorne mal was ich dafür
verwendet für die abfüllung brauche ich
300 gramm äpfel 300 milliliter apfelsaft
20 gramm stärke 30 zucker und jeweils
einen halben teelöffel zimt und vanille
extrakt jetzt werden die äpfel zuerst
einmal geschält und vom kerngehäuse
befreit und dann kann ich sie in kleine
würfel schneiden
[Musik]
gebe ich einen teil vom apfelsaft in den
topf da kommt die stärke dazu zucker und
zimt und vanille und jetzt kann ich die
zutaten klümpchen greife rühren und dann
den übrigen abgesagt zufügen
jetzt lasse ich die masse während rühren
aufkochen und kann ich zeigen wie ich
auf die kirsch bildung hersteller für
die kirsch füllung verwende ich die
kirschen aus dem glas und habe dafür den
kirschsaft erst einmal ab gegossen und
dann mit stärke und zucker in einem topf
verrührt
die kirsch füllung wird sich jetzt mit
etwas zitronenschale abrede und ein paar
tropfen bittermandel aroma und da lasse
ich die masse genauso aufkochen wie hier
beim apfelsaft
[Musik]
und sobald die soße kocht kommen jetzt
die äpfel mit rein und bei der kühlung
kommen dann die kirschen rein
jetzt kann ich das ganze etwa eine
minute weiter rühren vom herd
herunterziehen
und dann an der oberfläche direkt
abdecken und abkühlen lassen
jetzt geht's ans film ich mache jetzt
erstmal die apfeltaschen und habe jetzt
ihr blätterteig bereits ausgerollt ist
eine aus dem kühlfach und ihr könnt ihr
natürlich auch selber machen dauert
natürlich noch ein bisschen länger und
ich möchte jetzt auch das maß von der
apfel tasche gerne so machen und kann
das jetzt hier einmal kurz halbieren
[Musik]
und hier mag ich mir das jetzt einfach
nur jetzt kommt hier in die mitte etwas
füllung nicht zu dicht an den rand den
den muss ja noch verschließen
[Musik]
ich vermisste kirchstraße noch ein
bisschen marzipan auf dafür gebe ich
einfach marzipanrohmasse hier rein und
dann die kirschen drauf
[Musik]
jetzt bestreitet den teig an den rand
und hier mit etwas wasser damit die
teigtaschen besser zusammenhalten
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt die zweite schicht drauf
produzierende mitte so ein bisschen
zusammenrücken und dann durch schon
hätten
und bevor sie jetzt frittiert oder
gebacken werden kommen sie ins
gefrierfach
so bekommen sie nämlich eine bessere
konsistenz und sie verformen nicht wenn
ich sie jetzt hoch nehmen
so könnte es ja auch wunderbar
vorbereiten daher auch die große menge
ich mache jetzt gleich noch zwei drei
portionen dann könnte sie immer
eingefroren lassen und wenn ihr dann
lust habt auf uploader kirsch taschen
können der sie einfach frittieren oder
im ofen backen
die gefrorenen apfeltaschen können jetzt
frittiert werden ich mache das ganze in
der fritteuse und habe das feld auf 180
grad erhitzt ihr müsst jetzt nur daran
denken die dicke seite also die seite
mit erfüllung nach unten rein zulegen
ansonsten wird später das wenden ein
bisschen schwer weil wir brauchen sie
jetzt etwa vier bis fünf minuten auf
jeder seite
ich zeige euch hier noch eine variante
aus dem backofen denn ich bin
blätterteig hat er schon genug fett und
deswegen kann man es auch ganz gut im
backofen machen
ich habe ich jetzt ein ei mit einem
esslöffel butter zucker vermischt es
wird bekommen sie eine schöne farbe dann
kurz bestreichen und ab in den backofen
[Musik]
die frittierten teigtaschen habe ich
jetzt noch mit puderzucker bestreut
damit sie von außen auch ein bisschen
süße bekommen morello dazu werden man
muss natürlich dazu sagen der original
teig ist kein blätterteig weil der ja
auch nicht so aufgeht sondern eher
knusprig kross ist da hätten wir jetzt
zum beispiel den hefeteig machen können
ohne hilfe das hat mich aufgeregt zum
beispiel darf jetzt hier mal probieren
hier die frittierte variante da kannst
du ich habe übrigens die verpackung
einfach so ein bisschen aufgepeppt und
habe jetzt eine sache draus gemacht hier
alles nachgemacht tasche und ich musste
sagen natürlich ziel von 51 natürlich
fliegt also von der frau wäre etwas
geometrischer also hat die wand vor dem
backen auch geometrische ok aber in der
friteuse das hat das problem du willst
sie wenden und wieder weltmacht wieder
plus drehte und was hat er ist er wird
staffel cool ich habe kirsch eben
probiert dann ist doch so dass die von
models um eine schicht darüber haben
genauso eine ganze schicht war das zeige
ich dir das glänzt so richtig habe keine
ahnung ich habe schon gedacht vielleicht
zucker drauf aber das ist neutralen also
aber irgendwie geben es ist richtig
schön wenn die sind echt lecker man muss
also muss es ein sehr lecker aber ist
auch leckere apfeltaschen grad haben wir
dort 200 ich habe es auf der terrasse
tritt hier draußen zu kalt
ok also ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
glaube damit mehr zucker wo sie ein ich
sage ja eher die füllung kann man ja
süßer machen aber ich wollte jetzt nicht
sagen okay und schmecken halt anders
also ja ich bin also schlechter aber
auch wie muss ich ganz ehrlich sagt auch
nicht besser und wie schmecken einfach
andere ok cherie hatte nachmachen
geeignet würde ich mal ohne heiße
matches und nun geht es mit seinen
videos besser ist als gar mit essen oder
genau ob jemand anders also ich es
erzähle ich mal fachmännisch fachfrau
ist ein unterschied
die apfel
und kirsch taschen von mcdonald's habe
eine richtig tolle große große außenrum
datei ich etwas kompakter die füllung
ist wirklich super lecker man muss dazu
sagen bei mir schmecken ihm eine füllung
besser weil ich war den letzteren habe
und zimt und das ganze richtig super
abgeschmeckt hier gefällt mir gut das es
blätterteig seiner ist schon plaetrich
auf jeden fall zwei richtig coole sachen
also ihr könnt ihr mal auch das original
probieren möchte aber nicht oder
meistens wird wahrscheinlich größte ich
glaube in euro oder das war erich loest
den euro wahrscheinlich irgendwo stand
zwar drauf oder weil sie durch doch
gekauft
wahrscheinlich falls ihr das rezept
nachmachen möchte ich warte noch auf die
aus dem ofen auf jeden fall ist die
offene variante ein bisschen
kalorienärmer natürlich man hat in
blätterteig und nicht noch das
frittierfett außen herum
die ist vielleicht ein bisschen weniger
fett und falls sie das rezept nach
machen wollt dann schaut auf meinem blog
vorbei aufs ellis - blog.de
da steht noch mal alles ganz genau für
euch ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
also sagt villiger kann man sich mal
billiger kam schon jedes nicht weiß ob
er in berlin
aber wer weiß ist nachgebaut okay aber
ich mach's gut macht's besser
[Musik]
jetzt sind die teigtaschen aus dem
backofen auch darm und ich habe echte
werden schlechter aber die sind sogar
viel viel besser geworden
erstens mag finde ich sie optisch
schöner daher fotografiert mach es dir
jetzt auch noch mal und dann finde ich
sehr von der konsistenz her und auch mit
lanz herr viel schöner und viel
originalgetreu also die schmecken mir
besser deshalb mein tipp nicht
frittieren sondern im backofen backen da
bekommt sie den glanz vor allem die
richtig leckere kruste und sie sind
nicht so arg fällt also das nicht
mcdonald's nicht dass man es falsch
verstehen
[Musik]